My oncologist doesn't like how much weight I have lost.
You know, like an idiot all the time.
Tatoes, brown rice, pumpkin seeds, pecans, margins, any thoughts, any ideas.
They want me to start boost, but I'm not afraid of that.
What are your thoughts?
Well, I don't think boost is really going to help you gain weight.
If you are eating, you know, maybe good to start counting your calories, if you're eating,
you know, a ton of calories and you're still losing weight is that is a concern.
So, but the, you know, there's, there's a limited amount of things that you could do about that.
There was, there, I do have a video of cakexia, multiple, I think I have a blog post on cakexia
2, that I go over some different ideas, let me look at a really quick, I can share it with you.
Make sure it's still on our site.
Yeah, cancer cakexia weight loss and another, like a three, three-year-old blog post on cakexia.
So if you just go to our made website and then you search the top of the website where
you have that little hourglass thing right there and you just search cakexia, then you'll
see the multiple blog post on that because that's the term that is given to a person with
cancer that is eating, you know, plenty, seemingly plenty of women are continuing to lose weight.
So there's some kids that I give in those videos, I actually have several videos of cakexia that I want.